and Selena Gomez is finally up for best  actress in a musical or comedy for only  murders in the building really I don't  blame the player blame the game bruh no  don't do that yes this is her first ever  solo Golden Globe nomination after being  snubbed last year Selena's co-star Steve  Martin and Martin Short both receive  nominations and had a busy weekend  hosting Saturday Night Live and I have  to say that for me working with Marty  Short is like World Cup soccer somehow I  just can't get into it  cue the roasts while hilariously  delivering each other's eulogies the  hair we're joined by a surprise guest  now that Marty's gone who will I ever  work with  [Applause]  me  Selena had another SNL surprise up her  sleeve joining the two Martins again as  they reprise their roles in Father of  the Bride alongside Kieran Culkin time  for the big surprise your wedding  performer  oh  what's up everyone  Selena Gomez you're even more beautiful  in real life I know